c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
non c'est faux en fait on ne se rend pas
compte qu'on sorte les meubles avec ses
ponts parce que on passe son temps fait
ah mais c'est pour ça qu'on met des
chaussures pour se protéger les pieds
c'est l'une des particularités d'azur
c'est de protéger d'enveloppés son
poignet parce que on ne pense pas aller
chercher là où on ne les a pas mises
si on les cherchait à landreau ne les
avaient pas misé on tomberait sur elles
parce qu'elles seraient à l'endroit où
elle devait être
donc ça c'est un vrai problème mais vous
posez une bonne question vous avez
compris faut être parrainé faut se
démerder
enfin moi un endroit où on ne veut pas
je n'y vais pas personnellement en tant
qu individu connu je n'ai pas ce
problème
mais c'était si tu es et aider son père
mon pote tu rentreras jamais je fêterai
des raisons
[Musique]
pourquoi je ne sais pas parce que celui
qui a donné ce nom là j'avais dû prendre
l'avion il sait pas ce que c'est que la
peur mais quel chemin ils ne comprennent
rien je le dis au fil des émissions
ils ont des séries les mettre dans des
ordres ils n'ont pas de séries les
mettre dans l'ordre mais c'est
incroyable cette chaîne va à vau l'eau
[Musique]